Fastenbrechen an einer Tafel die solange
ist wie eine ganze Straße der Hunger und
Durst eines Tages werden gestillt
vielleicht doch der eines ganzen Jahres
einfache Arbeiter Essen hier viele
schämen sich dass ihre Not vor einer
Kamera gezeigt wird
das Leben ist sehr schwer geworden für
jeden besonders für uns
in der Küche steht Rami altussaini der
Sohn eines Bauunternehmers und gibt
Anweisungen Reis Kartoffeln Gemüse und
Fleisch etwas desto Männer draußen
normalerweise kaum zu sehen bekommen
einbissen für einen hungrigen sei besser
als tausend Moscheen zu bauen sagt al
Husseini aber dieser Ramadan sei anders
die wohltätige Tafel kostet ihn zwei bis
dreimal mehr
dieses Jahr ist sehr hart für die Leute
ich sehe das ich kann das in ihren Augen
sehen viele sind auf dieses Essen auf
unsere Hilfe angewiesen
[Musik]
Brot heißt Leben in Ägypten ein
Gradmesser für die Dinge im Land ist
brotbillig bleibt es voll ruhig kein
Land importiert so viel Weizen wie
Ägypten über 80% kommen aus der Ukraine
und Russland und seit dem Krieg
explodiert der Weizenpreis erklären Sie
in dieser Bäckerei die nicht
subventioniertes Brot verkauft
[Musik]
hat mal 4000 Pfund gekostet jetzt kostet
der 10.000 also mehr als das Doppelte
woher soll der Bäcker das Geld nehmen er
muss es vom Kunden nehmen er muss die
Fladen verkleinern damit er die Miete
und das Mehl bezahlen kann
ein Kunde sammelt ein paar Brote ein
fragt wie viel sie kosten als er die
höheren Preise sieht wendet er sich ab
für die Armen ist subventioniertes Brot
des Hauptnahrungsmittel das letzte Mal
als der Staat die Brotpreise dafür anhob
existierte die Sowjetunion noch es
folgten Unruhen kein Herrscher traut
sich seitdem an den immer höheren
brotsubventionen zurückgehen aber wie
lange noch wie lange bis die Wut steigt
dieser ein Viertel von Kairo wo die
untere Mittelschicht lebt eine Woche vor
Ramadan lernen wir Nora Ibrahim kennen
uni-absolventin Mutter von zwei Töchtern
jeder Einkauf bedeutet Stress für sie
soll sie das Gemüse nun kaufen oder
lieber abwarten weil vielleicht sinken
die Preise die Händlerin antwortet nur
so Gott will
wenn ich hier bin staune ich nur noch
ich drehe mich im Kreis und frag mich
was ich noch kaufen kann das wird mir zu
viel die ganze Lage
wir begleiten nur da durch die Straßen
ihres Viertels nach Hause wie bereiten
Sie sich hier auf ein Fest vor in dem
traditionell üppig ausgegeben wird eine
Zeit der Verschwendung der Freude
die Ibrahims Sayed und Nora sind so
etwas wie die typische ägyptische
Familie von nebenan eine Familie die
sich nun Milch und Joghurt für die
Kinder nicht mehr leisten kann das war
mal ein Luxus aus früheren Zeiten jetzt
müssen bohnenbratlinge reichen Geld für
den Arzt können Sie auch nicht mehr
zurücklegen die Kinder müssen gesund
bleiben
wir haben aufgehört an Obst zu denken
nur wenn wir etwas mehr Geld von
irgendwoher haben kaufe ich ein zwei Mal
im Monat Obst und wenn wir den Strom
nicht mehr bezahlen können wird er
nachts plötzlich abgeschaltet
was passiert in dem Land Präsident
abdelfatah Assisi ist in einer
notsitzung nach der anderen der Krieg in
Europa trifft auf hausgemachte Probleme
und wird zum Brandbeschleuniger
Investoren ziehen Geld ab plötzlich muss
Kairo seine Währung abwerten das Pfund
verliert 14% im Vergleich zum US-Dollar
das Land hochverschuldet muss den
Internationalen Währungsfonds um weitere
Kredite bitten die Emirate und
Saudi-Arabien springen Assisi bei für
sie ist Ägypten tubic to fail es darf
auf keinen Fall zu einem brotaufstand
kommen des Militärregime muss weiter
regieren aber reichen diese Hilfen um
den Kollaps zu vermeiden
also ich denke nicht dass das auf Dauer
hilft die sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
Probleme in Ägypten die gab es auch vor
diesem Krieg schon und da stellen sich
viele Fragen wie kann es zum Beispiel
sein dass Ägypten in den vergangenen
Jahren zum drittgrößten Waffenimporteur
weltweit aufgestiegen ist und jetzt
einfach wichtige Devisen fehlen um eben
diese Preissteigerung etwa für
Nahrungsmittel ausgleichen zu können
mono4 im fruchtbaren Nil Delta
der Kleinbauer ist HUK Muhammad Hassan
inspiziert seine Weizenfelder noch zwei
Wochen dann kann die Ernte beginnen
die Brote der Familie im heimischen
Lehmofen aus ägyptischem Weizen
per Anordnung der Regierung muss Hassan
nun mehr Weizen anbauen und 60% seine
Ernte abgeben an den Staat sonst droht
ihm eine Gefängnisstrafe
wir haben alles über Angebot und
Nachfrage geregelt aber jetzt gibt es
nur noch Fixpreise mit dem Händler hätte
ich verhandeln können aber nicht mit der
Regierung also muss unser Weizenpreis
doch fairer sein
kümmert euch und die Bauern sagt er noch
Hassan fühlt sich allein gelassen er
spürt die Folgen des Krieges in Europa
am Preis seines Düngers kann die
Regierung ihm da nicht helfen fragt er
und was ist mit dem Viehfutter der
Meister für kommt aus der Ukraine teures
Futter bedeutet teures Fleisch teure
Milch vom Benzin will er gar nicht erst
reden
zurück in Gießer was für eine Zukunft
hat meine Tochter fragt sich nur der
Ibrahim in diesem Ramadan wenn Millionen
Muslime ihr Fasten bei Sonnenuntergang
brechen sagt sie Stunden viele Ägypter
vor einem nie endenden fasten